carry the fight hi I'm Eric singer Erica
still a dialect coach who cannot stop
talking about linguistics today we're
going to look at some idiolect s-- an
idiot is one individual person's way of
speaking so we're gonna look at some
actors playing real people let's look at
some clips Jamie Foxx Ray Charles
making a record is business and find a
business deal that you can now can you
imagine so there's a posture thing here
that's interesting
Ray Charles smiles a lot his lip corners
tend to kind of pull straight back
towards his ears even when he's not
smiling it kind of hangs on throughout
at least a little bit yeah Jamie Foxx is
doing this is a pretty damn good deal
you know and he's not just doing this
he's not just doing it perfectly in him
he's living through it it's great I'm
very proud of the work that we've done
hit again I loved it I read it did
Natalie Portman Jackie Kennedy
she bought a lot of furniture for this
house he took the Lincoln furniture that
had been all over the house matter
husband rather cross so she went really
far with this going for a really
accurate a vocation of a very particular
voice it was where we lived when we
first came here with where we lived when
we first came here it's so strange to us
now and audiences responded to it that
way it's a huge risk I think it really
pays off I would hate Kenneth BAE man
there's incredible care with some of the
details here
listen to the tiny little sort of catch
breath right after the word most yes
they are the most famous twin of course
here's Jackie
yeah they are the most famous gonna put
and more thing in that line you can hear
a very particular kind of characteristic
inflection sort of movement of pitch
right at the end of the sentence when
she says bad the Lincoln best kind of
goes bad it's a little plateau and then
a fault Natalie Portman has that kind of
inflection possibility she doesn't use
it in the exact same place in this line
Lincoln bed an Incan Baghdad she does
use it just a little
earlier on the word are yes they are yes
they are see that's pretty cool that's
when you have an accent in you it just
comes out Forest Whitaker Idi Amin you
this would be a government action Forest
Whitaker prepped for a long time to get
Idi Amin's Ugandan English and it's
really good just pick two details out
that vowel sound in a word like first
moves all the way forward in the mouth
with a kind of a cupped tongue so you
get fast he's perfect on that okay so
there's a great little thing that he's
doing to which is absolutely accurate
which is he puts a little extra vowel
sound in in a couple of places this has
a fancy name it's called
a pen thesis it's pretty familiar if you
think of a kind of a stereotypical
Italian accent it's a me Mario
it's me and you can hear it here Jamaal
woolard the notorious b.i.g it was all a
dream
Saturday rep patek mr. magic volleyball
so Willard is from the same part of
Brooklyn that biggie was and that helps
a lot but he worked really hard to get
this down and for the most part he does
a really amazing job especially
considering he had to rap like biggie as
well as speak like him she was in no way
if I were gonna quibble I'd say what if
he uses a little bit too much
muscularity and detail especially in his
speech as opposed to his rabbits what
the is biggie I laugh at one point
the music was more poor there's a kind
of an ease a flow a slowness almost and
a lot of the articulation because well
it really is as his lips a lot to make
sounds come up and biggest lower lip
mostly remains kind of down a little
cooler and even out about half of
Americans make their S sounds with their
tongue tip down and about half make
their s sounds with their tongue tip up
take a second which do you do
Big E dance so I'll just stay more the
business everything will hurt the son
tongue tip out
I never sort of sort of sort of gone
before I make my aces with my tongue tip
up if I'd been doing them with my tongue
tip down my whole life it'd probably
sound pretty similar since I haven't
practiced it a lot though it doesn't
sound quite the same sir-sir state sir
you should try to get them to sound
exactly the same cuz why not
cool party trick Ben Kingsley Gandhi one
hundred thousand Englishmen simply
cannot control three hundred and fifty
million Indians if those Indians refused
to cooperate so Gandhi's accent actually
changed throughout his life and Ben
Kingsley's accent as Gandhi changes
through the film it goes from being much
more British let us begin by being clear
about general Smuts new law to sounding
much more stereotypically Indian it
would have been very uncivil of me to
let you make such a long trip for
nothing it's not stereotype though it's
really accurate one of the things that
is a common feature for most Indian
languages and Indian accented English a
retroflex consonants retroflex means
curling back and the tongue is actually
curling back like that it's flexing back
so retroflex civil resister the function
of a civil resister provoked response is
to provoke response continue to provoke
and we will continue to provoke and
till they respond or they change the law
you can hear those retroflex sounds all
through those words Kingsley if we
obtain our freedom by murder and
bloodshed I want no part of it Gani
everything around me it's ever-changing
it's incredible right
amazing brilliance Michael Fassbender
Steve Jobs two days ago we ran a Super
Bowl ad that could have won the Oscar
for Best Short Film so Fassbender has
said that he wasn't actually going for
any kind of imitation of Steve Jobs
let's start with me man it's not a
perfect match but Q it's really close
and it has turned out insanely great
this is so good
Wes so but still pretty good remember
he's not even an American no he's an
Irishman there's a really subtle kind of
drawn-out s sound that jobs and it eats
eighty eighty eight's for breakfast what
are you guys saying breakfast saying
another thing Fassbender gets is that
kind of slight nasality on ass sounds
apples history synthesizer sampling
faster faster faster Ashton Kutcher why
did they buy an apple because it's got
bravado playing a younger Steve Jobs we
got to put in the hours it's a process
of taking very centralized things um how
bad are you saying it's pretty bad get
out yeah we could but just get out no
it's bad everything your dumb Will Smith
Muhammad Ali man I told you I'm through
fighting from my intention to hurt
nobody
I got a much big contender this is a lot
of things that ignorant man a much
heavier opponent I'm fighting the entire
US government but I just think this is
amazing you know when you think of all
the time that Will Smith had to put it
into his physicality his body and
learning to box and you see how much of
the boxing he's actually doing in this
film
it's incredible that he had time to fit
in dialect where Kali comes out to meet
Frasier but Frei just starts to retreat
if Joe goes back and it's popping
you know wound up in a ringside seat he
worked really really hard with an expert
coach and the results are incredible
Ali swings with his left Ali swings on
the right just look at the kid Perry the
fight I love the way he has the rhythms
and the cadence and the pitch of Ali
crazy keeps back in but there's not
enough room it's only a mental battle
wound the way he lengthens a lot of
those final anonym sounds cuz he can't
start counting till Frazier come down
come down and here's Ali Frazier still
risin but the referee was a frown Sean
Penn
Harvey Milk so this is great I just want
to pick out one thing which is cool the
vowel sounded weird like force so it's
got a very kind of New York oh oh and
force is the lexical set word we use to
describe this vowel and we actually hear
the word force which is cool and you can
hear Harvey Milk himself doing it here
in the words abortion this income tax is
going through senior citizens a voice
abortion abortion and so forth and so
fourth fourth fourth of us and income
tax is no good twice in one Fred Alec
Baldwin Donald Trump God they were
loving this press conference it's good
to be with you to respect the press I
have great respect for the news let's
take another question from the press
right so this is a comedy impression
Baldwin's made a lot of really sharp
observations we stop giving him because
you were overrated we were getting quite
a bit of inaccurate news fake news and
of course he turned the dial up on them
he's exaggerating the features we have a
kind of a trumpet it out lip shake which
Trump really does and he does it more
listen that was locker room talk nothing
compared to what Bill Clinton has done
far worse okay minor words and his was
action but there are subtle things that
he's doing as well things that he's
doing with a vocal quality something
about the rhythm that's really cool I've
turned over
my businesses to my two sons my two sons
even Butthead who are right here we're
here today could we get a shot of them
Trump has a habit of lengthening out
some sounds the greatest jobs a producer
and really shortening up some other so
I'm gonna work very hard on them so
there's a lot of contrast okay this
Briscoe Altamont s it really well thank
you all for being here I mean for
pissing here but came Phoenix Johnny
Cash close watch
I keep my eyes wide I don't think
anybody would argue that this isn't a
brilliant performance it really really
is that has this way just for the sake
of it I'm gonna quibble there's one tiny
little sound that you can hear in Johnny
Cash's accent which is a quote sound for
WH words like when and whistle listen to
it in Folsom Prison Blues here's
Phoenix's version of the same song in
which he just uses a regular old Watson
I don't know well when I hear that
whistle blowing so you might say that
this is a tiny thing well no it's old
and it is it's a totally tiny thing and
again I don't want to take anything away
from this performance helps set the
place in the time I think or it could
and I think that's just an interesting
example of the ways in which really
specific details can just help kind of
support the story hopefully not in a way
that's distracting that just sort of
enriches it and brings us in John Wayne
Genghis Khan
[Music]
I share your taste in women target type
but not in blood like I said in the last
episode let this happen well charter
woman Meryl Streep Julia Child that's
exactly the sort of thing that I'm very
interested in learning how to do in
other words learned how to make sugar
syrup
she sends just like the real Julia Child
I'm so much water stops her heart it
just seems to be a pure emanation of the
person herself not just every single
technical aspect the range the
inflections the accent the mouth shape
but I do know how to boil an egg the egg
can be your best friend in this case I
think we get something of a sense of
Julia's sort of forthright flamboyance
as you want to be even joy in life from
this voice speaking French - wait what
you want Naomi Watts as Princess Diana
that's what we need isn't it you got it
it's almost as if he doesn't know who I
am one of the things that happens in
Diana's accent is that vowel sounds that
for me are diphthongs they get smooth in
the direction of being one single vowel
quality so instead of I we have
something like we wanted to smile smile
instead of oh we have something like
Tracy's choices listen to so follow and
don't know from Naomi Watts here so you
followed him followed him oh my generic
she moves in that direction but her lips
don't want to move listen to Naomi Watts
doing buying time and 5 we're buying
time putting two and two together and
making five so those price valves aren't
smooth at all
this is a detail but it's one that I
really would have liked to see many
years
he really would have helped contour the
character and the time and place in
social class for me Denzel Washington
Malcolm X now the house Negro he lived
in the house map either in the basement
or up in the attic let's just talk about
the vocal quality here stuff that you're
doing really in the throat right at the
level of the vocal folds themselves the
house Negro could afford to do that but
he never better than the field Negro he
dressed pretty good he ate pretty good
with the master leptin which sort of
come together like this to make voice
he's got kind of a gap and a little
rubbing there so we get that slightly
hoarse breath eNOS if the master got
sick he said what's the matter boss we
sick he's found a way to do it that
sounds a lot like Malcolm X he loved his
messed I say he loved his master better
than the master loved himself Kate
Blanchet Bob Dylan you know we all have
our own definitions of all those words
there would be no music without the
words all I ever do that is the most
important thing there really is I didn't
come out of some cereal box I haven't
really struggled for that there's no way
out there was ever gonna be converted by
a song if it did I would certainly tell
you so bloodshed is a really gifted
accent performer yeah oh yes she's
letting her oral posture here do a lot
of the work of evoking Dylan and his
famous voice song exactly personal
conscience for long time I couldn't even
sing it for you probably our jaws high
or lip corners that are slightly pulled
back the rest of her lips are soft and
there's kind of a narrow space in the
mouth but the tongue is really active in
doing a lot of the articulation I'm
bringing a draft card or bring yourself
okay we have enough time to course
there's some of that characteristic
almost stereotypical Dylan nasality
thank you very words but she doesn't go
over the top with that do we Jennifer
Lopez
Selena
[Music]
yes I'd imagine this is almost certainly
a case of little prep time and
inadequate probably little to no support
the thing is it doesn't seem to be a
clear choice I'm not sure if Lopez is
going for Selena if she's going for just
a touch of a Texan accent so you can
hear a pin pen merger pronouncing pin
and pin about the same in the word fence
fence but other times she just sounds
more like nothing JLo so maybe having
some little animals of our own Jesse
Eisenberg Mark Zuckerberg my attention
is back at the offices of Facebook where
my colleagues and I are doing things
that no one in this room including and
especially your clients are
intellectually or creatively capable of
doing okay so this is a really good
example of one approach to playing a
real person don't do them no Heisenberg
isn't going for a dead-on impression of
Mark Zuckerberg now this is what Mark
Zuckerberg sounds like when you put that
information in your profile that you
bought a scarf that's something that
your friends might find interesting
right now he is nevertheless evoking the
character or his interpretation of the
character through his speech that is
really good that's really good it's very
precise kind of articulation very rapid
or a tongue tip this is man whose mind
works really quickly you have part of my
attention you have the minimal amount
who's very precise everything is sort of
going over in there it just kind of
ridiculous it's all about ideas it's not
about relationships I think it's
probably a little bit of both by then he
doesn't suffer fools now like ever at
all and that was it that's awesome the
frame you and McGregor Alec Guinness
hello that yeah okay I know we're
cheating here obi-wan Kenobi wasn't a
real person though I do think but Alec
Guinness was he can go about his
business and this is so iconic that when
you and McGregor took over the role
playing obi-wan Kenobi oh this is gonna
be easy he had to find a way to do a
convincing younger version of
I have a bad feeling oh this I think it
has an amazing job in my experience
there's no such thing as luck
part of the particular vocal quality
that Alec Guinness had as obi-wan kenobe
more wretched hive of scum and villainy
so coming from opening up the faring
millions of voices suddenly cried out in
terror sort of stretchy open the throat
why was suddenly silenced and you can
hear a lot of that as a younger version
of it I do hope he doesn't try anything
foolish in Ewan McGregor's version I was
beginning to wonder if you've got my
message
these are not your droids Daniel
day-lewis Abraham Lincoln I am the
President of the United States of
America clothed in immense power we
don't have any recordings of Abraham
Lincoln but his voice was described by
contemporaries and they described it as
being surprisingly high-pitched kind of
Reedy and even whiny and what wouldn't
those numberless fathers are given to be
able to say to their sons 'as I now say
to mine so Daniel day-lewis constructed
something around the character that we
know as Lincoln and some of these really
famous really familiar words do you
imagine he'll forgive us if we continue
to stifle this very natural ambition so
the questions are basically does it
serve the story does it feel like the
character is it specific does it draw us
in is it integrates true because it
would what do you think did it feel like
a full three-dimensional real person I
think yes but I have to say it has been
done better dude Michelle Williams
Marilyn Monroe I'll be playing boo
shankha I want to be the best actress
that can be so this really strongly
evokes Marilyn Monroe without
necessarily going for that den on a
vocation I'm considering I important she
has that characteristic breathy Ness oh
yeah very much love the accent sounds
really good sure I don't like there's
one particular thing she may not have
been going for this at all but she
doesn't quite have that sort of little
girl tonality that Marilyn Monroe
developed how do you know how to answer
that two things
her pet that comes from a lot of subtle
shifts inside the vocal tract but a lot
of it comes from the way she sort of
holds her tongue forward in her mouth
you can hear it here that sort of very
forward tongue position let's say I
sleep in nothing but Yardley's lavender
Johnny Depp whitey bulger you would just
sayin just sayin could get you buried
all right let's talk about T's and D's
again you got two minutes it's really
interesting because he uses a particular
part of the front of his tongue again
and it's a lot of the front of his
tongue it's kind of a tip and some of
the blade of the tongue
yes so we're like this that's $20,000
for you to not it's not really close to
the teeth the way we might expect for a
New York or most Boston accent did you
marinate this steak but it is right for
Bulger listen to Whitey Bulger they said
that I don't know I forget what they
said
somebody threw my name in the mix and
here again is that take the money keep
your mouth shut about what you just
heard it's best you're not involved take
the money take the money take the money
so this is a little speculative but you
notice the way he presses that tongue
tip in quite hard and lets a lot of
pressure build up behind it to me that
almost suggests something about this
this psychopath you gotta tell him who
has all this violence but it's pent up
until it explodes let's look at that T
sound again take the money take the
money take the money now does somebody
who uses a sound like that automatically
have a lot of Rage inside them and does
it mean they're a psychopath no of
course not
that's not the way accents work but it
might contribute something to that
impression and how does he plan to
achieve that even if it's just letting
the actor feel like there's something
going on inside that's controlled and
then release
that's to mate Angela Bassett Tina
Turner we always do it nice all right
here's something really cool about this
it's kind of funny because I'm not
actually talking about Bassets vocal
performance every now and then I think
I'd like to hear something from us
something you need something maybe right
I'm gonna say something about what she's
doing when she's singing he's actually
Tina Turner she sings all of her own
stuff but Bassett obviously is
performing it and she's really really
figured out exactly how Tina Turner sang
watch her lips when you see this watch
the way they sort of trumpet out like
this
and here's Tina Turner so it wouldn't
have sounded like Tina Turner's voice
was coming out of Angela Bassett's body
if she hadn't gotten that detail right
Kevin Spacey Christopher Walken
checkatrade smell my feet give me
something good to eat
if you don't oh no I don't care I'll
pull down your underwear right so again
this is a party trick impersonation it's
not supposed to do anything other than
make us laugh and go wow yeah that's him
that's really good you know the a of
five it's in the ward he's a talented
impressionist I think he does a great
job be damned if any slopes couldn't put
the greasy of my hands on his boys
birthright it's like the Tony which I'm
up for he takes that one walk and
inflection crazy
and just repeats it oh my / what Wow
it's fun to do and it gets a laugh so
why not cocoon Cuba Gooding jr. OJ
Simpson well it won't be where it means
much longer oh that was something Bobby
have a good night huh
Oh so Cuba Gooding jr. took a lot of
heat for not sounding like oj this that
I did not and could not and would not
commit this crime doesn't sound like
this crime and that's okay it's totally
cool it's a conscious artistic choice
made by Cuba Gooding jr. and the
director probably not to try to do an
evoke ation of OJ's speech patterns he
worked a lot on the physicality and of
course on the essence the soul the
spirit of the guy but they left that
part of it out they asked me dead maybe
because they thought it would distract
in some way from the story Palmer
Falkner how much smoke does it work for
you
well it's a subjective judgment just
about this trial or you make the call
thank you your honor two other actors in
this same piece or doing much more to
kind of pick up the real speech patterns
of the people they're playing John
Travolta playing Robert Shapiro and
eight ah
that I take on a new criminal case I
wanted to hire the best forensic people
in the world I always ask the client the
question is your qualification statement
incomplete in that regard and Kenneth
Choi playing judge Lance Ito what tape
excerpts are appropriate for the jury I
know that you've made a commitment would
never suppress any information to see
this matter through Diana Ross Billie
Holiday don't so Diana Ross isn't really
doing anything when she's speaking to
evoke Billie Holiday but she really is
when she sings that particular tonal
quality that Billie Holiday had comes
from a lot of very very very subtle and
complex positioning of the muscles in
the throat she's somehow getting just
the right combination to really get that
Billie Holiday sounds I find this really
impressive it's incredibly subtle and
complex the particular things that
contribute to some of these individual
tone that kind of quality of their voice
especially when they're talking about a
great singer like Billie Holiday
Steve Carell John du Pont do you have
any idea who I am so I think Carell has
done something really interesting here
get any idea why I asked you to come
here today he's taken some very specific
accurate observations about du Pont's
actual accent you can hear a bit of
DuPont speaking here hi my name is John
du Pont
welcome to Foxcatcher farms it's got a
lot of the accent alone the bowel sounds
a lot of the oral posture his mouth kind
of stays open all the time throughout
slip corners a little pulled back and he
has those hesitations a weird long has
many aspects it feels like Carell has
slightly heightened all of those things
no oh you're right oh well though this
is just speculation yes I do for me the
effect is of kind of heightening the
sense of the characters loneliness David
Mike that sort of oddness a lot of work
to do I want you to tell me something
about the program is feeling trapped
inside himself that's a really crucial
aspect of the character athletic
tenacity against the fish at the hole
hinges on I win they lose don cheadle
Miles Davis how much imminence oh um I'm
two people in anyway I was born modal it
isn't net if you watch the last
installment I kind of gave Don Cheadle a
hard time about his cockney accent in
Ocean's eleven nylon are you accusing me
at booby-trapping you had one job to do
gives me great pleasure to be able to
say that this is just fantastic that
vocal quality that Davis had you might
think it's easy you just kind of go
raspy like that way you ain't no Walter
Cronkite I I ignore the critic but he
does it in a very particular way that
really matches Miles Davis sometimes we
find each other you know that's all I
know like a war
Miles Davis had surgery in 1957 to
remove a nodule in his vocal folds at
least in his telling he permanently
damaged his voice by yelling after
surgery what a nodule does is when you
have it on the vocal folds it prevents
them from being able to come together
and vibrate smoothly it's kind of bumpy
and rough yeah and that's why you have
that kind of hoarseness of coarseness
sure said dad so to be able to do that
it's really cool
Will Farrell Harry Caray oh if you were
a hot dog like a big chopper member and
you were starving everywhere of dramatic
would you eat yourself comedy impression
one three certain you just got to sort
of pick one thing you run with it Kerry
is very DJ's well he really doesn't send
a lot of air through his nose so it's
almost like when you're stuffed up and
you don't have at the end that could
come through that sure as God made green
apples don't jerk me around you do hear
a Farrell doing that extremely at some
points first I'll smother myself up
leaves you agree this brown mustard
relish
I'd be so delicious conclusion so you
know just in case you forgot
the stuff is really really hard even
more so when you've got the weight of
expectations you're playing famous
person somebody with an incredibly
famous or familiar voice there are
various ways of going about this various
artistic choices all of which are
completely valid you know ultimately
comes down to is it effective does it
serve the character does it serve the
story does it draw us in is it a real
full textured human being thanks for
watching